[Music]
each person's genome has about three
million single nucleotide variations
as well as many other types of genetic
variations
how do we predict the function of these
genetic variations
on may 14 2013 movie star angelina jolie
revealed that she has a mutation in her
brca1 gene
and that her mother died early from
breast cancer
to reduce her own risk of getting breast
cancer she made the drastic decision to
have both of her breasts surgically
removed
this revelation sent shock waves all
over the world
many people wondered and argued whether
she had made the right choice
the core of angelina jolie's decision
touches upon an important bioinformatics
question
given that she has a genetic mutation in
brca1
what is the conditional probability that
she will develop breast cancer
even with her mutation there is a chance
that she may be cancer free
these two probabilities add up to one
before we talk about how to calculate
these numbers let's first look at where
our genetic variations come from
we all know that we inherit genetic
variations from our parents
if our mother carries a particular
mutation allele there is 50
chance that we may inherit it from her
each of us
also have over 70 de novo single
nucleotide mutations that neither of our
parents have
many severe childhood neurological
disorders such as rett syndrome
are caused by de novo mutations that
disrupted critical genes
each of us also has somatic mutations
that are accumulated during cell
divisions
an extreme example of this is cancer
where somatic mutations cause cells to
grow
uncontrollably there are many types of
genetic variations in the human genome
different genetic variations may have
very different effects on the genome and
on the phenotype
the most severe is chromosomal
aneuploidy meaning that a person has one
or more copies of actual chromosomes or
missing chromosomes
the best known example is down syndrome
which is caused by three copies of
chromosome 21
or trisomy 21 which almost always have
been de novo
we never hear about trisomy 1 or trisomy
2 in humans
because these chromosomes are so large
and contain so many genes that having
abnormal copies of them is embryonically
lethal
another type of microscopic or
sub-microscopic genetic variation in the
human genome is structural variations
they include deletions duplications
inversion insertions and translocation
deletion is a type of mutation involving
the loss of genetic material
insertion is a type of mutation
involving the addition of genetic
material
many mobile elements are inserted in
each of our genomes
a novel sequence such as virus genomes
are sometimes inserted into our genome
there are two types of genetic
tandem duplications happen where a
segment of a chromosome is duplicated
right next to the original copy
intersperse duplications happen where a
segment of the chromosome
is duplicated to somewhere else on the
genome
deletions and duplications are often
called copy number variations or cnvs
finally two other types of genetic
structural variation that cause
disruptions of the genome
but not genomic balance include
inversions where a segment of a
chromosome is inverted
and translocations where a segment of a
chromosome is moved to somewhere else on
the genome
short insertions and deletions of one or
a few up to a thousand or several
thousands nucleotides
sometimes called indoles indoles may
happen in intergenic or intronic regions
or they may happen within protein coding
regions
within protein coding regions if an
endell involves three or multiplicity of
three nucleotides
it will only add or delete one or
several codons without causing a
frameshift
otherwise it may cause a frameshift that
may result in a complete change of the
amino acid sequence
often it would also cause a premature
stopped codon
the new protein may not be stable enough
to exist at all
at a smaller scale but with much higher
frequency there are single nucleotide
variations
on average in a person's genome there is
about 3 million snvs
roughly equivalent to one snv in every
one thousand nucleotides
snvs that are known to affect functions
and phenotypes the most are located in
the promoter regions or protein-coding
regions of genes
variations in utr and intronic regions
sometimes also affect function
most variants are located in intergenic
regions between genes
some of them fall in non-coding rna that
are transcribed but not translated
snvs within coding regions tend to have
larger effects than other variations
and those have been studied the most in
the more severe cases
snv can cause a premature stop codon
that terminates a protein early
in this example shown the cytosine
nucleotide is changed to thymine
as a result the codon cug that used to
encode amino acid of glutamine
now it becomes tag which is a stop codon
resulting in premature termination of
the protein
this snv is called a nonsense mutation
because a nonsense snv causes premature
termination of a protein
it is usually predicted to be damaging
even though there are exceptions where
paralegal proteins
or alternative pathways can compensate
for the loss of a protein
in the second example the adenine
nucleotide is changed to cytosine
as a result the codon cat that used to
encode the amino acid histidine now it
becomes cct
which encodes proline this snv is called
a non-synonymous or missense snv
because the codons are degenerative many
snvs do not cause amino acid changes
they are called synonymous or same sense
or silent snvs
some snvs at or near splice injunctions
may affect splicing
and finally some smvs change a stop
codon to a codon encoding amino acid
resulting in a lessening of the protein
which may have altered or disrupted
stability
structure and function synonymous
intronic and intergenic variations are
often ignored
however according to g was studies 88
percent of trait associated variations
of weak effect are non-coding
although individually their functional
effects may not be as obvious
because these regions are so large their
total effects cannot be neglected
especially a mild traits however
they remain understudied and better
methods are still needed
most research so far had focused on
misens snvs
a big reason is because known
deleterious mutations are enriched in
missense mutations
about 50 percent of all known mutations
of mendelian disorders are missense
mutations
however it is important to note that
there might be ascertainment biases
because an important discovery tends to
attract more research in the same
direction
however not almost since snvs cause
phenotypic changes
for instance brca1 was the first gene
associated with breast cancer
in 1990 based on linkage analysis of
large pedigrees of early onset familial
breast cancer
brca1 has a total of 238 known missense
mutations
163 are present only in patients
62 are present only in healthy persons
and 13 in both patients and healthy
persons
furthermore even the sense variations
seen only in patients are not all causal
if we look more broadly analysis of the
whole genomes of over 1 000 healthy
individuals in the 1000 genome project
revealed that on average a healthy
individual carries over 3 million snips
over 361 000 indoles almost
16 000 deletions over 400 duplications
and almost 5 000 mobile element
insertions
within protein coding regions on average
a healthy individual carries large
division that disrupt about 150 genes
over 1 000 stop coding snips 77 stop
losses
over 900 small frame shift indels over
700 small in-frame indels
nearly 70 000 non-synonymous snips and
sixty thousand synonymous snips
so the questions are what features
differentiate disease-causing variants
from neutral ones
how can we predict whether a variation
is disease-causing
unlike sequence alignment and sequence
database search
the questions here remain largely
unsolved
and there's still lots of active
researches going on